[Música]
Bienvenidos a la entrevista de France 24
estoy con William maloney economista en
jefe del Banco Mundial para América
Latina y el Caribe señor maloney es un
gusto tenerlo en Francia 24 en el marco
de la reuniones anuales del Banco
Mundial y del fondo monetario
internacional hay proyecciones de
decrecimiento en América Latina y el
Caribe para el año 2023 los puede hablar
un poquito de esas proyecciones que está
dando el Banco Mundial en cuanto a el
desempeño económico en la región este
nuestra proyección de lo que vamos a ver
para 22 20 22 y 23 es más o menos tres
como
0% para
2022 y uno como seis por ciento para
2023 lo de este año es representa un
aumento Comparado con lo que tuvimos en
abrir
más nada por el momento en los precios
de materias primas porque la región
y
el descenso en el año que viene y viene
más que nada de las asas de interés muy
altas en los países avanzados Bajos en
los
precios de materias primas y el lento
crecimiento en el i7 y en la china
quisiéramos saber también Qué efectos va
a tener en el crecimiento económico de
América Latina la guerra entre Rusia y
Ucrania
pues la guerra en Ucrania nos está
afectando un poquito menos que en otras
regiones del mundo pero el aumento en
los precios de combustibles y elementos
los precios de los elementos si nos
afecta con grados variantes a través del
continente y algunos países como
Colombia por ejemplo están beneficiando
un poquito por los altos precios de
combustibles mientras El Caribe por
ejemplo Es que donde importan sus
combustibles y su alimentación
están sufriendo más bueno y cómo se
puede proteger la región de Estos
factores externos teniendo en cuenta que
dependemos mucho de la producción de
materias primas de bienes tradicionales
bueno es difícil proteger la economía
en Sí porque las fuerzas de
globales que están llegando a nosotros
son muy fuertes Entonces hasta que china
recupere su crecimiento de la g7 también
y que bajen un poquito de interés vamos
a crecer lento más lento que el año
pasado que digamos
eso dicho tenemos que mirar a las
familias más vulnerables que están
afectados no solo por
elementos crecimiento que vamos a
esperar pero también por los altos
precios de nuevo combustible y si
alimentación
que forman un gran parte de su
presupuesto familiar el Banco Mundial y
el fondo monetario internacional también
están diciendo que hay un riesgo de
recesión en el 2023 usted comparte esta
visión de riesgo y de riesgo de recesión
sobre todo para América Latina Mira
los los que estamos enfrentando como
región están aumentando en caso de
interés bajas bajo precios de materias
primas
y
el alto crecimiento de China todos nos
va a afectar
pero estamos todavía esperando
pronosticando uno como seis crecimiento
del año que viene que nos recesión
algunos países
el crecimiento Sería mucho más lento
otros otros más pero eso es donde
estamos obviamente por ejemplo el hecho
que probablemente los Estados Unidos van
a subir las tasas de interés más estado
las noticias de hoy
Esto también implica que nuestras
autoridades monetarias van a
probablemente subir las tasas de interés
acá para el defender las monedas y esto
también puede hacer más lento el
crecimiento en la región hasta ahora
Estamos
pronosticando uno como siete por ciento
que todavía no es recesión y cuáles son
estos países grandes que más están en
riesgo de recesión y Por ende que
terminen afectando aún más la economía
de la región
sin más los países dependientes de
exportaciones de materias primas
pero es una combinación de cosas
combinación de político monetaria y
esas fuerzas y fuerzas externas las
tasas de interés parece que es como el
único instrumento que hay en este
momento para tratar de controlar este
tema de la inflación sin embargo hay
países como Colombia que se está
debatiendo sobre si subir precisamente
las tasas de interés pues al fin y al
cabo termina siendo beneficioso para el
país por los efectos colaterales que
puede tener para la economía
precisamente subir las tasas de interés
su opinión le merece este debate sobre
subir o dejar las tasas de interés como
están y los efectos que pueda tener en
la economía
pues ese debate se encuentra en todos
los países Incluyendo los Estados Unidos
hasta ahora haces autores El problema es
que para combatir la inflación tenemos
muy pocas herramientas y la herramienta
que tenemos
pues más poderoso es
subir la tasa de interés no Entonces
todos los autoridades monetarios están
buscando
este switch
no sé cómo se dice pero un lugar donde
estamos controlando la inflación estamos
defiendo la moneda pero no estamos
dañando a la economía
si se habla mucho también de los efectos
que pueda tener una moneda el dólar que
esté tan costoso tan valorada la moneda
con respecto a otras monedas en América
Latina Qué efecto cree usted que puede
tener esta alza continua de el dólar y
cómo puede hacer la región de alguna
manera para protegerse frente a este
dólar fuerte
pues Exactamente eso pone presión sobre
los bancos centrales para subir las
tasas de interés para que no salgan
Pues flujos de capital grandes no Y para
defender la madera es exactamente el
problema
hay dos lados de este modelo por un lado
No sé si las explotaciones más baratas
las más competitivas no entonces en
cierta forma somos más competitivas por
otro lado
estamos importando la inflación porque
las importaciones se vuelven más más
costosos entonces
el dólar fuerte es un fenómeno
que se encuentra por todos por todas
partes del mundo ahora y todos los
gobiernos están intentando
otro de los temas que se está
discutiendo mucho que hemos escuchado es
el tema del cambio climático que no
afecta solamente a Estados Unidos sino a
muchos países de la región cómo puede
ser América Latina para crecer pero al
mismo tiempo tratar de mitigar esos
efectos del cambio climático
pues obviamente este tema del cambio
climático nos preocupa mucho en el Banco
Mundial y en la región
como región producimos como 7 8% de las
misiones globales de
YouTube
y
hay varios países de la región que están
sufriendo duro de los impactos en
tormentas más fuertes en sequías se
encuentra por todos lados de la región
esto dicho como región estamos bien
posicionados para
la transición tenemos la la red de poder
como se dice el matriz de Electricidad
más verde del mundo porque tenemos
muchos renovables por todas partes de la
región tenemos en
desiertos tenemos donde se puede poner
plantas solares tenemos vientos fuertes
por todos lados donde se puede arrancar
la industria eólica
y hay varios países donde la industria
de hidrógeno verde tiene chance Entonces
yo creo que
es un reto tenemos que tomar medidas
defensivas no para hacernos más robustas
más resilientes a los efectos del cambio
climático pero también hay muchas
oportunidades para la región que tenemos
que aprovechar emitimos un informe Hace
seis meses precisamente sobre este tema
y
que Intenta dibujar Cuáles son los
proyectos y las oportunidades que
tenemos como alto directivo del Banco
Mundial y en el marco de estas reuniones
anuales del fondo monetario y del Banco
Mundial cuál cree usted que debería ser
el mensaje que usted le comparta a los
ministros de economía de la región para
mitigar este ambiente creciente de
riesgos económicos en el mundo y en
América Latina Pues todos los actores
aquí
los países que nos están visitando los
funcionarios del Banco Mundial estamos
en la misma página en cuanto a los retos
la economía global Entonces yo diría que
es menos una cuestión de que el banco le
está dando consejos es más una discusión
de Como cada país está manejando los
retos
como el banco puede ayudar
y manejarlo hay muchos gobiernos en
América Latina que cada vez más están
recurriendo a China como fuente de
financiación para muchos de sus
proyectos de desarrollo y algunos
analistas critican hay veces la falta de
presencia de otras potencias como
Estados Unidos usted ve esté creciente
protagonismo de china en América Latina
como un riesgo como una oportunidad del
Banco Mundial ha trabajado de la mano
con China para proyectos de desarrollo
en la región
Pues creo que cada país tiene que elegir
sus socios no Y tenemos este los retos
de desarrollo muchos ámbitos y
obviamente los chinos están jugando un
papel más fuerte en la región Bueno
vamos por países usted Cuáles cree que
van a ser los países que más se van a
ver afectados en el próximo año a nivel
económico Cuáles van a ser los ganadores
y los perdedores la región como total va
a crecer lentamente en los últimos en
los próximos años lo que me preocupa a
mí es más que nada que estamos
pronosticando dos como cinco por ciento
por 20 y 24 que es más o menos igual a
lo que dimos durante la década de los
2010 no esto nos dice que como región
América Latina está creciendo en forma
demasiado lenta para resolver los
problemas de la pobreza y para reducir
este las tensiones sociales entonces a
mí más que
enfocar demasiado en el tema de
inflación que si es un problema tenemos
que enfocar en Cuáles son las reformas
estructurales que tenemos que hacer como
países parque crezcamos a ritmos más más
rápidos digamos
que tenemos más energía y esto es lo que
me preocupa más que
más que nada y esto si le permite
seguimos con problemas de largas de
oración en por ejemplo la calidad de
Educación primaria y secundaria
en 30% los las empresas en América
Latina dicen que
su expansión está limitada por falta de
mano de obra calificada Ok en el mundo
en total como 20% Entonces tenemos un
problema y obviamente las calificaciones
pisa siguen siendo bastante bajas hay un
ejemplo en sobral en Sierra Brasil donde
han logrado avances enormes en un par de
años que tenemos que todos los países de
América Latina tienen que mirar para ver
cómo lo hicieron porque seguimos con ese
problema desde hace mucho tiempo
seguimos con una carencia de
infraestructura en muchas partes de la
región que lo hace difícil crecer
tenemos problemas y más de innovación
todo eso son los problemas que tenemos
que tener en mente dónde queremos estar
en 20 años entonces señor Manuel y de
nuevo Muchas gracias por estar con
Francia 24 ya ustedes Muchas gracias y
los invito a que sigan en la
programación de France 24 y France
24.com
[Música]